ابدا بضيفنا من كييف
وتقييمه لهذا الهجوم النهاري غير المسبوق
بعدد غير مسبوق من الصواريخ وايضا
بالمسيرات في ان معا
سلام عليكم
اهلا بكم نعم ربما ان هذا اليوم هو الاصعب
على كيف
لان هناك اجزاء عديده
كان هناك هجوم في الليل حيث تم اطلاقه
اربعين صاروخا
وعديد
المسيرات والان هناك صواريخ اخرى في الوقت
الحاضر لا نعرف كميتها بالضبط ولكن
في المرات السابقه جميعها كان هناك هجوم
في الليل فقط ولكن الان هناك هجوم في
الليل وهناك هجوم في وسط النهار
قبل نصف ساعه او ساعه تقريبا
قذائف في
مناطق مختلفه من كيف
سبب ذلك هو ان روسيا تتوقع من ان اوكرانيا
سوف تبدا هجومها المضاد
وايقافه او تفاديه
فانها تقوم بهذه الهجمات على العاصمه ومدن
اخرى وبالنسبه لذلك هو سبب الذي جعل روسيا
تكثف من اطلاق صواريخها ولكن الى حد الان
لا يمكن ان نقول ان هناك اضرارا جسيمه